er ist nicht hier er wird nicht kommen
und doch ist er allgegenwärtig von weit
oben sichtbar auf T-Shirts Autos und
Fahnen gedruckt und sogar in Fleisch und
Blut können seine Fans ihn bewundern
dieser Mann der seinen echten Namen
nicht preisgeben möchte verdient sein
Geld damit das Idol vieler Republikaner
zu imitieren er bleibt stets in seiner
Rolle die Leute finden es prima und
spielen das Spiel gerne mit
[Musik]
du bist doch der echte Trump oder
wer bin ich ich werde nicht zur Debatte
gehen es gibt ja keinen Grund ich bin
schließlich die klare Nummer eins die
anderen haben doch eh keine Chance gegen
mich
Mangel an Selbstbewusstsein war im
trampchen Kosmos hier noch nie ein
Problem das wird auch bei seiner
Anhängerschaft in Milwaukee with concern
deutlich dort hat der örtliche
republikanerverband zum Picknick geladen
Gedankenaustausch mit Gleichgesinnten
vor der ersten Debatte der Bewerber auf
die republikanische
Präsidentschaftskandidatur Gemütlichkeit
und Wut liegen hier nah beieinander vor
allem wenn man die zahlreichen Prozesse
anspricht denen Trump sich im Moment
stellen muss
die Regierung setzt das
Justizministerium als Wasser ein es ist
wie in einer Bananenrepublik sie
benutzen das Justizministerium um einen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten zu verfolgen
das ist doch alles außer Kontrolle so
etwas hat es doch noch nie vorher
gegeben
killeria billion ist Vorsitzender des
Verbands einer der jüngsten
Parteimitglieder in dieser Funktion der
22-Jährige betont er seinen Trump
Anhänger im liege ausschließlich etwas
an guter konservativer Politik wenn es
nach ihm ginge soll er Amerika
beispielsweise deutlich weniger Geld für
die Ukraine locker machen und die Mittel
eher für die Probleme zu Hause nutzen
[Musik]
viele Leute handeln sich von
Gehaltsscheck zu Gehaltsscheck ich weiß
wie sich das anfühlt ich habe selbst
Probleme meine Gasrechnung zu bezahlen
oder die Internetrechnung oder sogar
meine Miete alles ist durch die
Inflation teurer geworden also
finanziell abgesichert zu sein ein Dach
über dem Kopf zu haben das sind die
Dinge die meine Generation die
Generation Z die am Anfang ihres
Berufslebens steht umtreibt
auch nicht dass seine Interessen von
Trump angemessen vertrieben werden doch
mit seinem gewaltigen Vorsprung in den
Umfragen sei er nun mal der einzige
innerhalb der republikanischen Partei
auf den es sich lohne zu setzen
[Musik]
Trump konnte bei den Wahlen vor allem in
den ländlichen Gebieten Punkten zum
Beispiel bei den stolzen us-landwirten
wir besuchen die Vögel die Farm im
Hinterland wisconsens ein
Familienunternehmen in der fünften
Generation gegründet und aufgebaut schon
vor dem amerikanischen Bürgerkrieg
Bilderbuch Idylle im Herzen der USA
bilderbuchmäßig ist die Stimmung bei
Brian vögli und Carrie Sander aber nicht
das Paar leitet das Unternehmen das von
Trumps Steuernachlässen profitiert hat
trotzdem würden sie nie für ihn stimmen
die Art und Weise wie er die Demokratie
herausfordere machten ihn für Sie um
selber
ich kann trotzdem nachvollziehen warum
viele damals für Trump gestimmt haben
wir hofften auf frischen Wind auf
jemanden der die Dinge anpackt ohne in
dem etablierten politischen Pool zu
schwimmen
und an diesem Gedanken hänge ich noch
immer aber nach all dem was passiert ist
und wie er auf die Dinge reagiert hat
wissen Sie ein Präsident sollte nicht
dermaßen unreif sein
der sind ratlos wem sollen sie ihre
Stimme bloß geben in Zeiten in denen
Hass und Hetze die Debatte bestimmen für
sie sei es so kaum noch möglich sich
eine fundierte Meinung zu bilden
es ist wirklich schwer sich zu
entscheiden wen man denn nun
unterstützen sollte man bekommt ja bei
allem und jedem nur die negativen
Aspekte zu hören und das gilt für beide
politischen Seiten überall nur negative
also was sollen wir jetzt machen für wen
sollen wir stimmen es ist so schwer eine
Antwort auf diese Frage zu finden was
mich viel mehr interessieren würde sind
die konstruktiven Dinge was sind ihre
Vorschläge was wollen Sie tun um unserem
Land zu helfen
diesen und weiteren Fragen werden sich
die republikanischen Kandidaten am Abend
hier im kaiser-forum in milwauke stellen
und diese Studenten dürfen einige davon
an Sie richten sie gehören der Jan
Americas Foundation an einer Stiftung
für junge konservative Joel ist Leiterin
der Gruppe an ihrer Universität in New
Mexiko ihre Favoriten sind der
Unternehmer und Donald Trump seine
Vergehen seien doch viel weniger schlimm
als jener anderer Ex-Präsidenten davon
will sie möglichst viele junge
Wählerinnen und Wähler überzeugen denn
Trumps Politik sei großartig
[Musik]
wir müssen endlich aufstehen und sagen
hey wir kämpfen für ungeborene Leben wir
beschützen unsere persönliche Freiheit
wir kümmern uns besser um unsere
Veteranen ich denke dass meine junge
Generation gerade erst wach wird und
sagt wisst ihr was ich mache mich jetzt
stark und tue etwas für meinen Land
jamari green sieht das auch so
allerdings noch nicht sehr lange noch
2016 hatte er seine Stimme dem linken
Demokraten Bernie Sanders gegeben dann
stieß er online auf die Young Americas
Foundation ließ sich von den Inhalten
überzeugen wechselte die Lager er ist
sich sicher dass die Zukunft der Grand
old Party maßgeblich vom Ausgang der
Prozesse gegen Trump abhängt
[Musik]
ich glaube wir erleben gerade die Ruhe
vor dem Sturm es kommt darauf an wie die
Prozesse Enden viele distanzieren sich
gerade denn die Vorwürfe gegen ihn sind
massiv wenn er aber doch glimpflich
davon kommt wird er die Republikaner
stärker anführen als je zuvor
nach der Wahl 2020 hofften viele dass
der Lautsprecher der Nation nun leiser
wird das Gegenteil ist der Fall doch
auch wenn Trump sich am Ende bei den
Vorwahlen durchsetzen sollte die
Mehrheit des amerikanischen Volkes hat
er damit noch lange nicht gewonnen